foreign
voters in Italy have changed governments
about once every year tomorrow they'll
decide on a new leadership again in a
parliamentary election that could result
in a far-right candidate being elected
prime minister one big factor in the
race Italy's history Chris livesay
reports from Rome on what will be a
crucial election for Italy and for
Europe Chris good morning
good morning Italian politics are
chaotic much like the country well now
there's a party that says it can finally
instill order but its opponents say
those hard-right politics could take the
country backwards to a very dark past
they said it could never happen again
100 years ago Mussolini marching on Rome
plunging the country into two decades of
dictatorship an alliance with Hitler in
a second world war today the fascist
party is gone but many say these are
their political heirs the brothers of
Italy once on the fringes they've
ballooned into the biggest party in the
country now their leader Georgia Maloney
is poised to head the most hard-right
government since ilde the fundamental
problem in Italy is becoming the illegal
immigration too many immigrants for
example to protect the traditional
family a family composed by Mom
Italy's conservative Superstar remains
fiercely opposed to adoptions and
surrogacy for same-sex couples Maloney
has worked to soften her party's image
in recent years focusing on tax cuts
slashing the debt and raising spending
for low-income families but the fiery 45
year old hasn't dropped some of the
Hallmarks of Italian fascism
is a political scientist at Rome's
American University and that's clearly a
post-fascist party
with a post-fascist agenda it has the
flame in the symbol of the political
party that goes back to the idea of the
flame on the grave of Mussolini the same
flame is on Mussolini's grave yes but
why do they still have the same symbol
because the symbol is at the creation
and represents the creation the ideals
of a history okay
but if there was no connection with
fascism
why wouldn't they change their symbol
then no no no no no no that's more than
a red flag says Edith Brooke a renowned
poet and Holocaust Survivor
but are you worried yes very much
very very boring yeah I think that she
is fascist now this is the very balcony
where Mussolini would make those fiery
speeches those are images Georgia
Maloney say have nothing to do with her
party today but since she's never
governed the country before her
opponents fear that history could be
repeating itself for CBS Saturday
morning Chris livesay Rome